Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to cup head Sally stage play
Unfortunately is all done so for now. I don't know what ooh. Wait a minute. Oh hello you
There's another pirate ship down there that I did not see before also
I don't know
I don't have any more money to do any of that, but I did not see that pirate ship reach it up over there. Hey
It's the turtle I love turtles hey
I was going you boss think your situation is a multicolored mask
don't you but what if I told you that there was a way to see it in shades of grey a way that only a
Pacifist platformer would be able to perceive
Would you be file would you violent little mugs believe me if I told you that I wonder wait. Can you beat this game without?
Can you beat this game without killing anybody
Is that an option wait
Weird I don't know maybe it is an option, I'm not gonna try it oh god at all oh
Hi there oh sorry did I scare you huh, hey nice fish
You got the hole slipped right out of your hands. They're awfully slippery thing lady
You know maybe oh, there's that a seahorse ah whoops. Oh that what the hell? Oh, oh it doesn't hurt me
It just pushes me upwards okay, man lady. You know maybe we don't need to fight so much
Maybe you and I maybe you and I we can get along you know slappa. I got real
Good slapper skills you know if I'm saying. Oh, sorry. I wasn't paying attention those saw them wow
That fish that fish you're a cutie. I'm not sure if I should catch a release oh hey
Yeah, I am a cutie. Hey, you know
Did you know that I can go invisible
Yeah, I bet you didn't know that very true very true. Hi turtle how you doing. Oh that that doesn't seem friendly
Why are you like a foghorn, I don't I don't like that fine, I know you know I shouldn't judge so much
I like you the sound of your voice baby. Oh, sorry. Did I see okay here comes the fish?
Whoa I forgot about that fish. Oh all right, then all right, baby. What you doing? What are you doing?
Not the turtle again. Oh well there. She go no not another one ha ha slap. Oh shit
I did not
This fish is not happy about whatever she's doing to it. Okay. All right. I'll bite take it seriously now. Yeah boy. Oh
Yoohoo! Indeedy do
Yoohoo! Baby oh, I don't like that one. Oh, yes. I do slappa slappa slappa slappa all over the place oh
Don't let it slip out sorry and now you're gonna
Bow baby boom. I'm sorry
Just the way life is sometimes. Oh, Oh bye apparently oh, oh it's gonna be problematic
Whoa wait whoa whoa whoa whoa? Whoa not that problematic not that problematic at all
Right baby. Oh Oh
Oh got it. That's always how it goes. I goof it up all at once in one go of things
I just goof things up all over the place come on
Oh geez so many bullets so many bullets so many bullets so many bullets bullet hell bullet hell bullet hell
All right, bullet out got it
Oh my god, I don't like what you've done with your hair. That's awful. Oh my god. That's awful oh
That's cheap. That's cheap that is cheap. Oh my god. I'm not even halfway through this oh
All right, this is gonna be a tough one then okay
How do you want to flip that tire didn't even notice the turtles are full of your dukes put up your books?
Put up your dukes
Slappa slappa there we go
Skadoosh key, baby, sorry Oh
Wolk aye again, not ready for it don't know why slappa slappa come on
Oh, that was so slap a territory that goofed me harder than I goofed it oh
Wow, wow wow wow oh I was right there damn it. I was right there. Okay. It's okay
Well, this one is gonna be tough. I can tell this one's tough long fight lots of room for error. It's a doozy slappa
Slappa. Oh, this is your mistake lady
Giving me the full slappa before I even get off to the races there oh
Yeah, how's a good slapper No oh? No? Oh god damn it? Oh?
God oh god
May I say Oh Oh
No God they bite it right on her midriff, but God, you know some shout somehow
She's even more attractive than she once was I don't know what it is, but I just I can't help it got some
It's really appealing in some way
Okay, I do the jiggle like the joystick jiggle maneuver
You guys saw me slapper you guys saw me slapping I stopped with that
Alright, whatever. I'm getting better all right. Oh
Oww aah oww aah oww aah oww?
God blast these guys to hacking back whoa what blast slapper. I don't know how I missed that slap up oh
God it always aah. That's a shitty technique. That's a shitty. That's ash. Oh god. I forgot. That's what that do clear up
Slap oh really slap oh really
I'm trying my best
Wow I
Shouldn't that shouldn't have happened that shouldn't happen. Okay. You know the bomb technique
That's nice, and all bomb seems to do a lot less than I think it does it's just for AoE
I'm guessing just for hitting a bunch of people which again might be good for that for
Okay, we're gonna start off with a bang here. We're gonna start at Walla sue she poisons me
Boom baby all your buddies are gone. Oh shit of course of course right off the bat right off the bat like a idiot oh
Not today not today not today. Not today. Oh wow today apparently
I wish I wasn't so terrible all I want for Christmas is to not be stupid
No, oh no. Oh, no. Don't freeze me now no
Oh god I was looking at my soup. I looked at my super she just ah
Lady I'm gonna show you a good time just get bare with me here. I got skill. I swear. I got skill lady
Oh boy here we go here. We go here. We go here. We go. Oh test of skill oh
I was in the clear. I looked at my super meter like an asshole
I don't know why I'm not using my dodge like for some reason
I'm just not using my dodge like on the mundane things. I don't know if I think like I'm a like wasting it
Oh shitty dicks. I don't understand myself when I do that. I just can't be close to her
That's the thing I I think it really is just me being close to her
I can't be close to her no matter how much I want to
Considering how attractive she is, but I just cannot be close to her especially when she's forking up a ghost storm. Yep. There's
C again it's like every time. I I don't understand why
What's the slap really
Here we go here. We go here. We go bye umm, baby
There we go okay at least I'm getting Phase three war I hate Phase three. I hate phase 3 phase. Waah. Oh
I didn't know that's what that was gonna be I did not know. That's what that was gonna be
Alright, I can get there again. I know what I'm doing maybe I sound pretty confident. Don't I ah
Really really really really really really?
Really really really, but I'm really that doesn't really happen did it really happen. God. It did didn't it okay here we go
No, no come on that takes too long to get over okay?
Why why why why why ah okay here we go oh
Yeah, I'm sorry, but you became to be capitated like a lot of the people in this lane
You're still very attractive, but god damn it. I don't think I want to go in a second day with you. Hi
I'll call you don't call me
Good golly Miss Molly not bad not bad not bad tough tough tough that one down took a while
I own took almost like 15 minutes shit. Oh boy
Yeah, okay, but I got it. I got a calamari yeah all right, Cala, Maria
Hey listen. I'll meet up with you later. I just
Got some business to take care of on the other side of town, baby. I don't know if you know about it but uh
I'm uh I'm a rolling stone, baby. I don't stay in one place for one long
I gather too much moss on my ass. If you know what I mean, and it's always facing west so
Got a roll-on buy into the railroad Rath. I don't know what this is all about but okay
I don't know if I'm gonna beat this one in time
Oh a ghost
All right, well, that's an option. Okay. Well this is it peculiar this makes it handy. I can't hit that all right. Oh
Whoa what the heck? I've wha oh?
Hey, oh, I get it oh I see oh I see I see I see this oh I didn't know that
So that's uh, that's the crux of this endeavor all right, so this seems easy enough just got a counteract those wampie loose oh
what the
It froze
its sucking vibrating uh
Mr.. Musashi I missed you oh
Okay well that that froze and 85%
I'm 85% done with this game. Holy shit
I didn't even know that it's weird that the devil owns a ghost soul
Or is owed one at least which is rather peculiar. God. I can barely hit this guy cuz I keep having to hit his eyes
Which is a weird weird statement to say I guess out loud now that I'm thinking about it. How are they so?
Sad you over there, okay? Well that was stupid of me
Well, he's gone. I guess I should have the other super equipped
I'm now 100% positive at the other the other super is a much better
Much better thing for this particular scenario good ol horizontal blast shit. Well. I'm dumb here. We go again
I
Jumped right into it I didn't I can see into the future you will be counting worms
Well good that means. I'm not dead I guess even if I was dead nad worms in me
I guess I wouldn't be counting him. Okay, okay, okay, okay?
You know you need to calm down with your stupid eyeballs
I don't take too kindly to that and I'm gonna do some of this as well
somehow oh
Really, I'm walloping him. Oh shit. Oh, shit. That wasn't good. That wasn't what the doctor ordered, okay? We're fine though. We're fine. Oh
Got the double flapper okay, what's next what's next what's next Oh
Dreadful it goes boo keys, ooh
Spooky, Oh God. Okay? Well don't jump up apparently Jesus. Oh, oh this ain't good. This ain't good daddy
That's not good miss me, I guess
Peculiar about that well alright. Oh wow that is precarious
I guess oh
I jumped why did I jump? Why did I jump? Why did I jump? I'd have no idea. Why job that makes no sense
Now go stop
Me all right well, let's see how this goes oh
I jumped again. Why did I jump? Why am I jumping there? Why I got him like halfway through with that one super
Why did I jump? Oh who knows? I'm very stupid very
Incredibly exceptionally stupid it's a wonder that I've even made it this far. Don't you agree come on you all right?
How am I gonna screw this up is the question of the day there? We go nice and easy
Just very gently
Allow him to do his thing
Okay, well there. We are Oh a little
Okay, it's alright. It's okay. I'm a happy camper as they all say easy peasy all right
All right where am I going? What am I doing? What am I doing one of them is one of my noona?
What a man what a man who know what I'm gonna. Do oh, I don't like this
Oh, I don't like this at all. Oh, I don't like this at all No what are you doing? No?
Now shit. Oh, I see okay all right. That's
That's peculiar. Okay, so whoever is about to blow
Go to the other side as fast as you can no
Yi, well I'm on a dire night oh
Geez oh why?
all the pink the pink thing landed on the other one it sent me over ah
Shit, I do so good, and then I start yapping my big flap or jacker. Yeah, that's how it always works once
I start open up my power, then things just fall apart
mysteriously
No mrs.. If I have no control over the matter
It's just all conundrum is thing anyway. Well anyway here. I go gonna do one of these manoeuvres
Little bit pretty good for you, you're gonna like this gonna like this you're gonna like this you're gonna like this
Who is starting with who are we starting with what's going on here? Who's you who are you nice nice nice epic?
Yeah, that's the good stuff. Oh, I stood right on it right on it
Oh boy, whoa? That's not good, or it's very good. I don't know
All right, well he's dead all right. What else is new it seems relatively. Oh hey. Hey, buddy. You don't look so good oh
Oh, that's that's scary. That's very scary all right. I don't know what - oh hello. Oh shit. I didn't see that oh
No oh shit
Okay, I know what I gotta
Do you gotta hit him on the tail I bet probably the only way to actually damage him
What a cheesy way to win this I'm just standing here. I'm just standing here and shooting up. That's all I've done
I'm not even moving this feels so cheating it feels it's
Strategist rity chick, that's what I'm doing
I'm just being a strategic Big Easy Phase II lemon squeeze me
All right, well tell is a thing okay one down well again very easy
almost cheesy
Lemon squeeze me and dead alright. Well this has been a nice adventure I
want to see if I can stay over here that way I can be near the tail because I think I saw that and I'm
Gonna, I'm definitely gonna take advantage of that. You don't seem to be oh
Come on
There we go oh oh oh oh
Okay, oh okay, that hurts. Okay? You're you're problematic, but I can take you there
We go there. We go there. We go okay bone-in coming off shit. Okay, you're not gonna. Get me. Oh shit
You might get me. Oh you might get me
Oh, that was not bad not bad not bad not bad oh
Man
Alright one of these days. I'll try the other weapons out, but I don't need them who needs them
This is so good. So anyway. That's all the time. I got for this episode. Thank you everybody so much for watching
Apparently I'm almost done with this game so the next episode might be the very last one, but thanks again
Let me know what you think down the comments below as always Oh, we'll see you in the next video
Buh bye